people are asking about I see Mike and
this man I see Mike was this man when I
was growing up in my neighborhood they
had this dude I see I see Mike and he
would always get these what he would get
water from different parts of the
country and he'd freeze it at his house
and so in the summertime you know in the
summertime we'd go over to his house and
have different types of ice from
different places you know we have you
know he'd have all kind of stuff you
know
salt water brackish you know he'd have
uh you know something that had a little
too much mercury in it you know some
illegal [ __ ]
he'd have some Lake Mead a little bit of
you know um Gulf of Mexico that's you
know that's easy we have different River
you know the chief funk talked all I
remember one year he got a couple
buckets of the Colorado and he would
freeze it into chunks and we go over his
house and eat it and kind of you know
it's like a little vacation it was a
little bit of a vacation because some
people got to travel a lot and when I
grew up you went traveling anywhere did
nobody took it man I remember this
pedophile dude or this trucker his
long-haul trucker put me and my buddy
Michael and Michael had some
deficiencies he had extra salivary
glands and his face needs to leak out of
his mouth and he had a sitting in his
truck playing again playing a game of
how many tootsie rolls could we each put
in our mouths dude and at a certain day
young age you think it's just a fun game
you know and he you know and I'm putting
some in Mike's knife he has is putting
them in each other's mouths you know and
we don't have an idea where children you
know we eleven year old children and so
we sitting in the cab of this 18-wheeler
putting that this dude that we met off
of a CB radio this man showed up in the
neighborhood off of a ham radio and this
dude pulls up next thing you know me a
[ __ ] drippy my car sitting in this
Michael Michael I don't want to say the
boy's name but he but anyhow he um this
man had us putting uh putting tootsie
rolls and he tells mouths and Counting
how many we could get into each other's
mouths and I'm not saying something's
wrong with that but I'm saying
something's wrong with that you fricking
creep I hope that man just I don't know
I hope something bad happened that man
cuz you're not supposed to do that and
that's the kind of thing see I'm not
doing that kind of [ __ ] with kids I'm
not out there playing stupid games with
candy you know I'm a safe reliable
person around children and family and
this man had me and [ __ ] drippy Mike
Michael putting these in each other's
mouths man and Michael little Michael
put about manas dude had I don't think
he probably put about 17 into his mouth
I put about 11 in and he put about six
in himself and I tell you this truck
drivers sitting there probably hard as
[ __ ] dude because that dude was probably
a damn creep but thank God man this
other this guy named Clint you know like
like kind of like Clint but with an in
Clint he came and he whooped that man's
ass when he saw that man had us in his
truck cab and I'm thankful to that man
and that was I'm pretty grateful for
that but yeah this but anyhow this dude
I see Mike would have us over to have
different Isis you know for because when
you were young you didn't travel much
and what I was saying was that trucker
that picked up me and this other kid
Michael drippy Michael he used to he he
offered to take us to Florida and when I
was growing up Florida was the only
place to go when you grew up in
Louisiana if you met somebody who'd been
of Colorado or something that didn't
make any sense to you you're like what
how did sure guy okay okay sure buzz
aldrin sure you went to Colorado
but if because the only place to go
growing up in the south was Florida that
was it
where have you been at Florida where you
headed Florida if you saw somebody to
come in from school came in from summer
break and they had a t-shirt on this
head floor it on it with a picture of
the son of petrova of a palm tree and a
beach and a little sunset good chance
whoever was wearing that was gonna do
some [ __ ] in that year because that's us
that shirt shows that they have been
somewhere they I've been traveling you
see some of this other [ __ ] Wisconsin
you're like what is that Wisconsin is
that a church what is that you know what
happened because in the south you know
when you're in the south you do you just
you live but you
you grow up with a lot of traditions
everything is very traditional and you
keep it small like that I'm sure it's
the same for like Missouri like Lake of
the Ozarks or
you know like in Wisconsin like um or
Michigan like upstate Michigan you know
like um the Upper Peninsula or something
like that or over on North Carolina and
South Carolina like probably the Outer
Banks you know like the these places
where that's where people went for
vacations and so that's what we kind of
um you know that was the only place to
go growing up was Florida the only place
to go was Florida so what happened oh so
I see Mike would get these places would
get these treats you know this frozen
water we go over there he'd freeze up a
batch of it and break it up with a
hammer and we'd all be sitting over
there eating a little bit of um you know
foreign water so something from
somewhere else and it was pretty good
man it was a nice treat because for us
that was like taking a vacation you know
we might not get to like a you know lake
minnetonka but that doesn't mean that we
weren't gonna have a crushed
sack of it you know and be you know you
know take the end of it you know to get
the bag at the end you got little bit of
water left in your bag you ate all the
ice you just dripping the water on each
other's bare backs and [ __ ] like that
and being chill and just an you know it
was like a chance to take a vacation
without having to go anywhere having
them exotic ices and this dude I see
Mike and I talked about that on Coco
Diaz his podcast you can you can listen
to that podcast and check it out good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one